la agenda comienza el lunes entrada a la
tarde el féretro de isabel segunda
saldrá del palacio de holyroodhouse
hacia la catedral de saint gilles la
familia real encabezada por el rey
carlos tercero acompañará en el ataúd de
la monarca una vez en la catedral un
servicio religioso se llevará a cabo
para celebrar el legado de la reina el
féretro de la monarca permanecerá en
capilla ardiente durante 24 horas para
que los escoceses puedan dar el último
adiós a isabel segunda en horas de la
noche una vigilia encabezada por carlos
tercero tendrá lugar allí el martes el
cuerpo de isabel segunda será trasladado
a londres en un avión de la real fuerza
aérea en la capital será recibido por el
rey y la reina consorte en el palacio de
buckingham se espera que el miércoles el
cortejo fúnebre se traslade en las
primeras horas de la tarde a westminster
hall en la sede del parlamento donde
permanecerá por cuatro días mientras se
desarrolla todo el programa previsto el
nuevo jefe de estado carlos tercero
llevará a cabo una agenda paralela en la
que se entrevistará con varias figuras
políticas de la nación e instituciones
como la primera ministra de escocia y el
parlamento escocés así como otras
personalidades de irlanda del norte